27 septembre 2006 à la surprise générale
le gouverneur républicain arnold
schwarzenegger en pleine campagne
électorale défi le président bush il
signe une loi qui engage l'état de
californie à réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre aux normes de kyoto
biken
depuis quelques mois arnold
schwarzenegger s'est trouvé avec
l'environnement un nouveau thème de
campagne fait rassemblement
et personne ne l'attendait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était en 2002 à schwarzenegger et qui
est à new york pour faire la promotion
de sa voiture préférée l'homme l'une des
voitures les plus gourmandes en
carburant jamais construite aux états
unis
elle est très belle et ce n'est pas trop
voir ce qu'elle a dans le ventre
elle a fait ses preuves tous les champs
de bataille au fur ça c'était le
terminator en 2004 un nouveau
schwarzenegger un manque de popularité
présenter un autre moeurs futuriste
cette fois-ci équipé d'un moteur à
hydrogène le gouverneur a décroché du
sénat californiens un budget de plus de
6 millions de dollars pour faire la
promotion de cette nouvelle technologie
en principe moins polluantes pour
l'instant ça ne marche pas vraiment et
donc ça ne dérange personne surtout pas
les compagnies pétrolières qui contribue
largement aux campagnes électorales du
gouverneur pour la séance photo arnold
schwarzenegger a fait monter les décors
d'une station-service à l'hydrogène
nous ne ferons pas imaginer l'autoroute
à hydrogène
rêver à des stations-service hydrogen
chez nous n'allons pas seulement rêver
aux voitures à hydrogène nous allons les
conduire
aux gens que c'est le futur mon songe
que nous avions une chance de nettoyer
l'air de nettoyer notre environnement
pour les générations futures dans la
réalité s'il existe bien quelques
prototypes le moteur à hydrogène n'est
pour l'instant qu'un produit de
laboratoire et un coup marketing du
gouverneur
le ralliement d'arnold schwarzenegger la
cause environnementale ne s'est vraiment
affirmé que très récemment quelques mois
des élections comme des milliers de
californiens il a eu la révélation
regarder
le film en question s'appelle une vérité
qui dérange son mode
candidat démocrate malheureux face à
george bush en 2000 le documentaire est
un exposé sur les dangers du
réchauffement climatique
sa sortie au printemps dernier
le film a déclenché une véritable prise
de conscience et à haut niveau
c'est une crise planétaire les solutions
doivent
chacun
c'est vrai que les états unis sont
responsables du racing problème
avec le réchauffement climatique les
stars et producteurs d'hollywood
puissants lobbys ont trouvé une nouvelle
cause à défendre
nous sommes ici dans les studios du
coloriste et en dirigée par linda
cette productrice profite de son
influence et de ce contact pour monter
des opérations médiatiques destinées à
sensibiliser l'opinion publique
américaine
c'est elle qui ont monté la fameuse
opération
avec entre autres la cuisse seulement
sur les dangers du réchauffement
planétaire et ses conséquences
de la musique cinéma pour attirer le
jordan assure médiatique dont nous avons
besoin alors que nous avons à
linda tient à nous faire découvrir
l'objet qui est devenu la mascotte du
mouvement écologique d'hollywood
alors prius sai devenu le symbole de
green star le mode de reconnaissance de
l'erreur
et ma porsche carrera
la prius est une voiture hybride elle
associe un moteur essence et un moteur
électrique ce qui réduit la consommation
d'essence et limite la pollution
je crois que nous sommes
de sa porsche ps ainsi que julien louis
[Musique]
la campagne des stars d'hollywood
déclenché un véritable phénomène de mode
autour de la voiture japonais
toyota qui a vendu cent sept mille prius
en 2005 est incapable de répondre à la
demande
les clients se les arracher paye 5000 à
10000 dollars au dessus du prix de vente
qui est voisine pourtant les trente
mille dollars pour un modèle bien équipé
3 c'est une première
la fièvre verte atteint même les classes
moyennes et les banlieues républicaine
nous sommes ici à newport beach
vainqueur de l'orangé county ces
passionnés de la prius ont fondé un club
et ils se retrouvent tous les dimanches
pour admirer leur voiture et bien sûr
parler écologie s'est clôturée
formidable pour les passagers à
l'arrière
ma tête touche presque le plafond on est
très confortable maintenant
regardez il ya même des poignets pour se
tenir
oui c'est bien
90% de pollution au moins par rapport à
n'importe quelle voiture de sa catégorie
après avoir fait le tour des voitures
ces militants écolos citoyens
consommateurs d'un nouveau genre se
retrouvent dans le salon pour parler
environnement
l'agencé de protection de
l'environnement ils disent qu'on a déjà
eu 85 jours
d'un jour sur 3 où l'on respire de l'air
morte
moi j'ai acheté cette voiture en voyant
les pubs
message est il qu'on l'ait bien fait
d'être gentil avec l'environnement était
vraiment
cool
elle adoucit sentiment
on représente de la population et on
utilise 80 % des ressources de pétrole
bayard
wahou kilométrage illimité kilométrage
était
la voiture et la pollution sont donc
devenue objet de débat politique en
californie en pleine année électorale
c'est même devenu
une affaire d'état pour la première fois
de l'histoire les procureurs d'un état
de l'union ont décidé d'entamer une
procédure judiciaire à l'encontre des
six plus grands constructeurs
automobiles de la planète l'homme chargé
de cette affaire c'est le procureur
canal ex
vous ne présentez pas avec le
réchauffement climatique
pour l'instant les constructeurs
incriminé chrysler general motors ford
toyota honda et nissan ne prennent pas
l'histoire au sérieux il dénonce un
complot politique
typique de la défense c'est un acte
politique tout ça c'est pour
un consensus sur le fait de prendre
cette histoire au sérieux et d'attaquer
le problème climatique
nous avons choisi cette période tout
simplement parce que les scientifiques
n alex veut obliger les constructeurs à
respecter des normes de pollution plus
strictes il veut aussi obtenir des
dommages et intérêts pour les dégâts dus
à la pollution dont sont responsables
les véhicules une affaire qui n'est pas
sans rappeler les célèbres plainte
contre les compagnies de tabac
il pensait que les tribunes ou n'allait
pas prendre
les constructeurs automobiles ont la
même approche et j'espère qu'au tribunal
l'état de californie lutte contre la
pollution des voitures pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
mais pour le simple citoyen c'est aussi
le coût de l'essence qui le pousse à
trouver des solutions alternatives
le prix de l'essence a augmenté de 50%
en un an
william lui a trouvé une solution pour
ne plus acheter des sens grâce à un
véhicule pas comme les autres
photographe installé dans le quartier
est de los angeles williams s'est acheté
il ya quelques mois cette vieille
mercedes crise elle qu'il fait tourner
avec de l'huile de cuisine
je conduisais une
voiture qui
viole donc évident des trucs qui tombe
en panne
à supporter ça pour pouvoir utiliser ce
williams arrive dans sa station essence
préféré un restaurant indien
ici la friture est une spécialité est le
patron est bien content de se
débarrasser de ces huiles usagées
est un habitué après un petit bonjour
aux patrons il s'en va recueillir son
précieux carburant dans l'ariège panne
ce qui est bien avec les restaurants
indiens leur huile depuis
que je suis venu voir le patron de ce
restaurant et que je lui ai demandé si
j'essaie
vraiment de
retour à la maison williams doit filtrer
son huile dans un container la pompée
dans un jerrycan et là enfin on peut
faire le plein moins rapide que la
station-service d'accord mais aussi
beaucoup moins cher
combien d'argent avez vous économisez
depuis plusieurs mois
williams a acheté deux autres vieille
mercedes pour le reste de sa petite
famille
rouler à l'huile de cuisine permet de
faire des économie c'est aussi une façon
d'affirmer sa conscience politique
on ira soyons lucides c'est bien une
histoire de pétrole se l'avouer la
dépendance
franchement à quoi ça sert aujourd'hui
de me noyer les nos 1 à 4 4
si vous n'êtes pas un écologiste cela
perd comprendre et c'est juste une
question de bon sens
le boom du moteur à l'huile a commencé à
silver lake le quartier bobo de los
angeles
c'est dans ce garage que les vieilles
mercedes de la ville obtient une
nouvelle jeune hâtives le petit journal
qui est à l'origine de cette opération
un bricoleur et spécieux qui a mis au
point un système qui permet de remplacer
le gasoil par de l'huile végétale
une mécanique simple qui permet de
filtrer l'huile puis de la préchauffé à
l'aîné moi je n'ai rien découvert à
l'origine le moteur diesel tournée
l'huile d'arachide c'est drôle de voir
les gens se tenait au fait que c'était
le carburant à l'origine de ce jeu très
bien les jeunes et
les huiles du bonheur voiture et celle
qui a confiance et bonne voiture
l'installation ou de 700 dollars et
depuis plus de six mois la liste
d'attentes ne cesse de s'allonger la
petite entreprise de brian devient
florissant le succès de l'offre kraft
attire tout le monde est aujourd'hui un
client très particulier doit apporter sa
voiture
on arrive aujourd'hui à mort le hummer
de schwarzenegger
il avait fait tout ce barouf disant
qu'ils allaient conduire meurt à
l'hydrogène jamais marché
le hummer du gouverneur schwarzenegger
est discrètement amené au garage le
lendemain matin il s'agit de son vieil
homme meurt diesel une pièce de
collection
c'est une version militaire ancien alors
scharzenegger est devenu écologie
pendant qu'il fait discrètement
transformer son hummer pour rouler à
l'huile de friture le gouverneur
schwarzenegger est happé père dean la
célèbre université de malibu devant les
caméras elle qui représentait pour la
troisième fois son fameux projet de loi
sur la réduction des émissions des gaz à
effet de serre à quatre semaines des
élections
la mise en scène est parfaite
il n'y a rien de plus important que de
protéger notre planète
j'espère que vous êtes aussi fier que
moi aujourd'hui alors la californie
deviennent un modèle sont faire face un
des plus gros problèmes de notre époque
le réchauffement climatique et la
protection de notre environnement
pays comme l'inde et la chine le brésil
au mexique ou si héron que ce que nous
faisons et ferons
qu'un jour le gouvernement se joindre à
eux
ce petit sourire et bien évidemment
adressée au président george bush avec
cette loi le gouvernement fait coup
double il se positionne comme défenseurs
de l'environnement et au passage il
prend ses distances avec le président
américain dont la popularité est au plus
bas dans les sondages seul ombre au
tableau un petit groupe de manifestants
qui a loué des hummer pour protester à
l'entrée du campus
utilise un peu plus d'essence et
les amis j'ai
[Musique]
rien de mieux
les gens je fais moi un petit bisou
la police de malibu qui n'aime pas
beaucoup ce genre de plaisanterie va
vite interpellé les farceurs et vérifier
leur identité
une identité vous au fait loi je suis
fichée quelque part c'est juste par
curiosité
vous pouvez être aussi curieux vous
voulez je veux juste vérifier votre
identité
4,4
font la pause c'est un acteur se
protestataires
après vote et nous le retrouverons
quelques jours plus tard dans un meeting
du parti démocrate nous apprenons qu'il
est en fait un des chefs de campagne du
candidat fils angelocth le principal
rival barnaul schwarzenegger pour
l'élection au poste de gouverneur ce
chef d'entreprise d'origine drake
entouré aujourd'hui de ses plus fidèles
supporters c'est que détrôner le
governator sera une tâche difficile
i know what they bateau n'a rien à
35 millions de dollars pour des six
compères par la même équipe qui a fait
les barges et chiliens 2004
il faut y aller glaner
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de régulier avec le mot nation pour ce
pétrole
il a été au nouvel
environnement dans la victoire
comment peut-on être
gouvernementalisme alice croisé bruno
depalle george bush sur sa tête
et pour l'instant cela marchait bien
puisque arnold scharzenegger dispose
d'une avance de 15 points dans les
sondages pour tenter de rattraper son
retard fils à jo light va parcourir
l'état jusqu'aux derniers jours avant
l'élection le pari est il perdu d'avancé
la réponse d'abris cote le conseiller en
dit long sur le moral des troupes chez
les démocrates
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore une fois les
électeurs
ne votent pas
même sur le ruban et l'environnement il
s'en fiche
ce soir avery crottes va rejoindre ses
camarades démocrates pour regarder le
débat télévisé entre leurs candidats et
le gouverneur schwarzenegger
ce sera le seul débat public de la
campagne et avery crottes c'est que
c'est peut-être l'opération de la
dernière chance pour les démocrates
arnold schwarzenegger semble serein
détendu cravate et le vert il apparaîtra
ce soir encore comme le défenseur de
l'en qui ont surgi avec
continue exactement ce que nous faisons
depuis
par exemple comment
win-win devenir moins dépendants du
pétrole la différence entre le
gouverneur et moi il reçoit plus
d'argent des compagnies pétrolières que
n'importe quel politicien mise à jour
est une erreur de débutant en regardant
la mauvaise caméra pendant les trois
premiers quarts d'heure du
public et ont fait un travail
fantastique vers 2,7 rabat en accord
avec mes collègues
sur la couverture d'un magazine
mais je vous dit quelque chose
le profil
et le programme d'arnold ce n'est pas
que l'environnement nous sommes ici à
trabuco canyon au coeur du fief
républicain de californie
un club de bikers est venu accueillir
son héros qui pour l'occasion a su se
remettre en selle
ici les arguments sur l'environnement
n'accroche pas
les militants sont venus voir avant tout
le candidat républicain et la méga star
d'hollywood
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
utah a conservé de mike me donne de
l'espoir non mais sérieusement tanguer
sérieusement parce qu'elle attendait bbc
il ne faudra que les pas qu'ils
deviennent amicales ont aujourd'hui le
gouverneur ne parlera pas
d'environnement à son assistance pour
faire vibrer sa base républicaine il
revient des valeurs sûres
je sais que si j'ai pu réaliser mon rêve
américain
c'est grâce à tous les braves de ce pays
ils se sont battus pour la démocratie et
la liberté
je leur dis merci merci de risquer votre
vie pour protéger les nôtres
je suis impatient de nous servir à
nouveau
ce jour là le candidat ne portait pas de
masque ces supporteurs ont retrouvé le
vrai républicain celui qui croit aussi à
une politique conservatrice sur matière
d'économie et qui suit rigoureusement la
ligne tracée par le président george
bush sur les sujets de société sensibles
comme le mariage homosexuel la peine de
mort est avec la défense de
l'environnement arnold schwarzenegger ne
prend aucun risque et il est sûr
le républicain qui sait se faire élire
anita majoritairement
[Musique]